>>> THE BEGINNINGS OF A STROKE
CAPTURED ON LIVE TV.
TWO NEWS OKLAHOMA ANCHOR JULIE
CHIN SUFFERED A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY ON AIR WHEN SHE BECAME
CONFUSED AND STUMBLED OVER HER
WORDS.
>> TULSA -- THE TULSA AIR
RESPONSE SPACE MUSEUM AT THE --
AT THE -- AT THE EVENT -- THE
EVENT FEATURES LIVE -- I'M
SORRY.
SOMETHING'S GOING ON WITH ME
THIS MORNING.
AND I APOLOGIZE TO EVERYBODY.
LET'S JUST GO AHEAD AND SEND IT
OVER TO METEOROLOGIST ANDY
BROWN.
>> AFTER TOSSING TO THE WEATHER,
THE PRODUCTION TEAM CALLED 911.
SHE SPENT THE WEEKEND BEING
TESTED AT THE HOSPITAL.
DOCTORS BELIEVE SHE EXPERIENCED
THE BEGINNINGS OF A STROKE BUT
THANKFULLY NOT A FULL STROKE.
WITH US NOW IS CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT DR. SANJAY GUPTA.
SANJAY, I WATCH THAT AND I HAVE
TO SAY THAT WAS SCARY TO SEE
THAT RIGHT THERE.
HOW COMMON IS SOMETHING LIKE
THAT, AND HOW CAN YOU AVOID IT?
>> WELL, IT IS NOT COMMON,
THANKFULLY.
IT IS SCARY.
IT CAN SOMETIMES BE DIFFICULT TO
FIGURE OUT, YOU KNOW, JUST FROM
A NEUROPERSPECTIVE.
I'M A BRAIN GUY.
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR IS IN
HER CASE SHE WAS HAVING
DIFFICULTY FORMING THE WORDS
WITH HER MOUTH, YOU COULD TELL
SHE WAS HAVING DIFFICULTY
FINDING THE WORDS AS WELL.
AND THAT OBVIOUSLY IS
CONCERNING.
YOU SEE IT TRANSPIRE ON LIVE
TELEVISION.
WE NOW KNOW THAT IN HER CASE, AS
YOU POINT OUT, IT SOUNDS LIKE IT
WAS THE BEGINNING OF A STROKE.
THERE WAS A SIMILAR EPISODE,
THIS HAS HAPPENED IN THE PAST AS
WELL, BACK IN 2011, YOU MAY
REMEMBER THIS WITH SERENE
BRANSON.
>> LET'S GO --
>> AGAIN, DIFFICULTY FINDING AND
FORMING WORDS THERE.
AND IN SERENE'S CASE THAT WAS A
MIGRAINE, AN OCULAR MIGRAINE
THAT CAUSED THOSE SYMPTOMS.
IT CAN BE DIFFICULT TO PARSE OUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE.
IN JULIE CHIN'S CASE, SHE'S 47
YEARS OLD, SHE WOULD GO TO THE
HOSPITAL, WHAT WE SUBSEQUENTLY
LEARNED AS WELL IS THAT SHE HAD
SOME DIFFICULTY WITH HER VISION,
SHE ACTUALLY BECAME NUMB ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF HER BODY AS WELL.
AND THAT'S WHY THE DOCTORS
THOUGHT IT MAY BE WHAT IS CALLED
A TIA, TRANSIENT ISCHEMIC
ATTACK, OR THE BEGINNING OF A
STROKE.
BUT IT SOUNDS LIKE SHE'S
RECOVERING WELL.
WHAT YOU MENTIONED AT THE END,
THEY CALLED 911 RIGHT AWAY.
NO MATTER WHAT, NO MATTER WHAT
YOU THINK IS GOING ON HERE, THAT
IS THE RIGHT DECISION.
THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO
BECAUSE TIME REALLY MATTERS
HERE.
AND PEOPLE HAVE OFTENTIMES HEARD
THIS ACRONYM FAST, BUT THEY MADE
IT BE FAST NOW.
AND PEOPLE SHOULD MEMORIZE THIS.
BUT BE FAST STANDS FOR FINDING
IF SOMEONE HAS DIFFICULTY WITH
BALANCE, THAT'S THE B, E IS EYE
PROBLEMS OF SOME SORT, FACE,
FACIAL DROOPING IS THE F, ARMS,
YOU PUT THE ARMS OUT, SEE IF
THERE IS DRIFTING OR WEAKNESS OF
THE ARMS, DIFFICULTY SPEAKING,
AND THEN CALL 911.
THE QUICKER SOMEONE CAN GET TO
THE HOSPITAL, CERTAIN THINGS CAN
BE DONE TO TRY AND MITIGATE HOW
STRONG AN IMPACT THAT MIGHT
HAVE.
>> ONE OF THE THINGS YOU NOTICE
THERE IS SHE IS HAVING A HARD
TIME READING AND YES, FORMING
THOSE WORDS, BUT WHEN SHE GOES
TO JUST SAY, LIKE, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON, I'M GOING TO
SEND IT OVER TO THE WEATHER
PERSON, SHE SPEAKS FINE.
SO IT IS THIS MAYBE IT IS A PART
OF THE BRAIN OR I DON'T KNOW,
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT WAS,
SANJAY?
>> I THINK THAT SHE WAS HAVING A
FEW THINGS.
ONE IS THAT IT WAS THE FORMING
OF WORDS, BUT ALSO SHE HAD
DIFFICULTY WITH HER VISION.
HER VISION STARTED TO GO BLURRY.
MAYBE SHE WAS READING
TELEPROMPTER, SOMETHING EARLIER
ON AND THEN SHE HAD A SENTENCE
SHE KNEW WELL, AND SHE WAS
TOSSING AND THAT CAME MORE
EASILY.
IT CAN BE DIFFICULT TO FIGURE
OUT, BUT WITH THE STROKE,
SEVERAL DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
BRAIN COULD BE AFFECTED AT THE
SAME TIME.
GIVE THAN SHE HAD RIGHT SIDED
NUMBNESS, MOST LIKELY THAT WAS
AFFECTING THE LEFT SIDE OF THE
BRAIN.
LEFT BRAIN CONTROLS RIGHT SIDE
OF THE BODY.
AND THAT MAY HAVE BEEN WHAT WAS
CAUSING HER SPEECH DIFFICULTY AS
WELL.
WE DON'T KNOW FOR CERTAIN, BUT
AFTER TESTING, T